your father was an author he wrote a
book called families which was about his
family in Mississippi Grandpa and also
it was about my brother and I and the
family he created with my mom and so he
died when I was 10 and the book was not
a huge bestseller but for me it was like
a letter from my father and so it's
something I have read multiple times
every year in my life because it's I
hear his voice in that book and it's you
know it's been a guidepost for my life
how wonderful is that yeah to have a
book of your father writing about your
family yeah and since he had lost him at
10 years old you probably don't really
remember even him I had not heard my
father's voice since I was 10 years old
because there you know there were there
were no recordings of it and uh years
ago a guy named Charles Ruiz who was a
radio interviewer reached out to me and
said to me I interviewed your father in
like 1976 when his book came out and the
interview has just been restored and put
online it was for public radio and he
sent me the link and I sat in my office
and I clicked on the link and my dad boy
my dad's voice
I heard my dad's voice for the first
time since I was 10 years old and um
yeah it was incredible gift yeah it was
a gift and you know what's weird too
you'll never know really what your
father was like but you've got this book
and this recording Not only was it my
dad being interviewed but he was talking
about me and he was talking about my
brother and what he hoped for us the
loss of your father at 10 and the loss
of your brother from suicide I mean
that's pretty heavy background I what
I've I've come to realize that I
actually have never really grieved uh my
dad or my brother that I just buried
everything and just moved forward and
you know I was concerned about my mom in
both those situations I felt I needed to
you know help her and
yeah it's only recently in the last
several months that I've suddenly
realized like oh my God I like there is
um like an ocean there's uh there's a
lot I have just like pushed deep down
I'm doing another season this podcast on
Grief really because I want to talk to
people about grief the last episode I I
made a voicemail but and I asked
listeners to call in with something that
they had learned in their grief that
might help others and I didn't plan on
doing another season but I felt
obligated I wanted to listen to All of
the voicemails because I had solicited
them and I thought I should listen to
them all because people have called in
with very intensely personal messages so
I've spent the last couple of months
listening to
listening to 46 hours
and um
it has
clearly impacted me very strongly
hearing other people's grief it made me
react in a very
like this and uh it may and then I
started wondering why am I reacting like
this why is my voice quivering right now
and I started to realize uh how little I
had actually allowed myself to feel this
this stuff and it doesn't go away it you
know you can push this stuff down uh you
know Marge Simpson once told Lisa
Simpson like you know just put a smile
on your face and push everything deep
down and I I remember watching that and
laughing about it at the time but that's
what I've done and so yeah so it's all
like it's bubbling up even like right
now and I yeah and isn't it unhealthy
Anderson when you don't realize you're
doing it you're pushing away all this
grief and you're not allowing yourself
to feel it going to Wars was part of
me wanting I couldn't feel I couldn't
allow myself to feel stuff so I I wanted
to go places where things were so
overwhelming that I would be forced to
feel I wanted to Bear witness to the
suffering of others and I wanted to
understand how people survive I I wanted
to understand why two people my brother
and I living in the same house growing
up with the same circumstances one of us
made it out alive and the other didn't
and
um
but all those mechanisms that I used
they're great to I mean they're not
great but they they enabled me to move
forward and and get where I am but they
are inhibiting
the full enjoyment of of a life and I
think it's time to to figure that out
foreign